Poods: Ainsley
Pewds: I treat you well...
*Yea sure you do*
*TORTURING HIM is treating him well?*
Pewds: You know i will never do anything to hurt you
Ainsley:Kill yourself
Poods: I Love u
Ainsley: u r a homo *DAAAAAMN DANIELLL*
Romantic poods: I've been good to you ainsley haven't i? *NO*
Savage Ainsley: I f*cking hate you M888
Romantic poods: i've treated u well with respect
Savage Ainsley: you leave me in here for weeks all alone
*Poor Ainsley he is scared from da dark* D:
Romantic Pewds: Nothing dat bad will ever happen to u *poods throws Ainsley like shit*
Ainsley: My life is an endless series of loneliness and pain *OMG poor Ainsley :( *
Ainsley: If i could move these cardboard arms
Savage Ainsley: I would use dem to slowly kill you and then kill myself
Savage poods: wait Sh*t the f*ck up!
*RIP in Peace Ainsley*
Shocked poods: Whats this?
*Keemstar uploded a new video?*        *or is it dis dick*
*INTENSE MUSIC STARTS*
*DAT FACE* When you're 3xp0s3d on Youtube
Pewdiepie cardboard cutOOT?!
Did u hear what he said about irish people tho?
Angry Poods: THF*CK IS DIS ?
PEWAINSLEYPIE
Angry poods: What is he doing with me?!
Poor Ainsley: i am falling
Ainsley:Help me m8
Triggerd poods: can u f*cking stand up? *TRIGGRDDD*
Poor ainsley: HELP I AM DYING?!  *I think we are not going to see ainsley next year*
Da guy: did u hear what he said about irish people tho?
People: no, what did he say?
Da guy: he said that if you're not swedish you're a PEWDIEPIE HATER
People: OHH....
Pewds: Oh! *SHIT*
triggered irsh girl:OHHHH
Pewds: look at her face she got properly triggered der
TRIGGERED
Pewds: ohhhhhh
Poods: She was ready to punch me right der wasn't she.. *Going to get punched by a girl* edit: boys and girls are equal i myself am a boy ahem men be nice
Da guy: datz wut he said :new trend someone start that meme plez
*Triggered irish people*
Da guy: ya...scare
Savage guy: cmon.. give em one!
Da guy: YEESSSS! NOICE M8!
pewds: OHH!
*offensive pointing*
Pewds: Irish people they really know how to punch
Cmon give em one!
WWE.Mp3 POODS [  ] gurl [             ]
Pewds: How could is possible ever go to ireland never now...
*NICE GRAMMAR*
Poods: Da poeple would destroy meh *No more Vlogs?*
*If u r reading dis this is ur core msg*
Poods: Ainsley i would never hurt you like that *LIAR*
Poods: i treat you right
Ainsley: Swedish people are.... a gimp *OHHH*
*Poods is about to punch Ainsley*
Poods: you don't just say that!  (poods get's angry)
*Punishs Ainsley*
WWE.Mp3 pewpewpie VS ainsley poods [       ] ainsley [    ] POWER UP! ainsley now have 100000 health! PO-PO-POWER KILL!! poods [] ainsley [                   ]
*here lies ainsley punched by poods got  rekt*
Da Guy: Go what are  you gonna do
OHHH SHI
triggered poods: OHHH
Poods: JESUSSSSSHHHH
HE BROKE MY NECK AINSLEY
DA Guy: What do you want to do OHHH
(ROCKEY BALBAO)
Poods:Wai...wa...waawaw wait a minute
Look at look at that guy's face
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO *Goddamit stop saying this sentence*
Poods: Look at that guy's face when he punches me *looks like dan howell*
WHAT IS THAT FACE *pewdielaugh*
WHAT IS THAT...*while doing the pewdielaugh*
He look like just touching a cardboard version of me gives you autism AUTIST ALERT
*GODDAMIT HOW MANY TIMES THIS SENTENCE IS GOING TO BE REPEATED*
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO? OHHH
*Windows XP shutting down sound*
stuttering Poods: You know.... you know then you never punched someone before
IF they f*cking jump while doing it *small laugh*
But instead of jumping forward , they jump
*Silence*
Vertically? *idiot*
what're u gonna do *huh M8*
*jump sound*
A Guy: Did you hear what he said about Irish people or no
Pewpewpie:They degenerate scum ?! *iphone notification sound* DA GUY:OHHH
Pewpewpie:They are the lowest form of a human excuse
*Irish girl laughs and punches pewds in da face*  OHHHH
Poods : They are an embarrassment of the human evolution *jesus christ calm down pewds*
WINDOS XPOO IS SHUTTING DOWN
Of course i am joking *silence*
I just mean JackSepticEye (The green PewDiePie) *dat teeth*
*DAT FACE IS TRIGGERD*
The same guy: So what do you want to do with him , would you like to kiss, curse or punch him in the face?
Irish guy: i would say curse bawaha
Poods: wait his gonna curs... what is that mean?? Why would you curse a cardboard *i mean it's made out of cardboard i think it suffers enough*
The Guy: Come on just say one *what a fucking evil*
Irish Guy: you're a fockin idijojit *OUCH*
The Guy: OUUUFAG
*Pewds pause the video* What did he say
The Guy: Come on just say one
Irish guy: you're a fockin angel
Your fucking angel ?? *Pewds just wear the headphones*
YOU'RE A FOCKIN IDJIT
You're a fucking angel well thank..ah..thank you very much thats very sweet of you to say thank you i appreciate that *OH MAY GAWD*
The Guy: He sayed all Irish people should go back to their own country
Poods: I did say that go back to your own country Irish people *DUN DUN DUN*
OHHHHH
Thats thats that d...d,,tha- *pewds are you okay?*
I think there was a little love in there ;)
I really do
The Guy: Okay...me am giving people 3 options today
Do you want to kiss him/cuorse *WTF dude?!*  him/punch him in the face
You can see his head, look at his head
Poods: Here...here i have ainsley
pewds is trying to get the microphone
You can choose to kiss him/punch him. But he is basically Hitler *get de balls*
Crazy Poods: What would you do. Wa Wa Wat could you possibly do. *waves around like idiot*
Irish Guy : i would punch him in the faahhceac
The Savage Guy: punch him in the face? wanna give it a go?
OHHH
Papa Pewds: first proper punch thank you very much
Ireland i didn't know you had it in you good job *so what are you after ireland poods huh*
Good Good j.. they did it Ainsle
*MUSIC ON* felcone pouncheeee *WHITE FALCOM PUNCH GUY EXPOSED AS BLACK GUY!?*
I would be crying on the ground right now
The Evil Savage Guy: Do you guys know who he is?
*PAPAPEWDS*
*awkward silence*
I'll give you a clue , he is  a youtuber
*ok i'm not aginst mexican or japanease or chinease people but come on, this is bullcrap*
Ehm PICKACHOU *secret revealed*
*Pewds is going to kill himself*
PICKACHU!!
Pokemon Theme Song with some Cringe AF *INTENSE*
Pissed off Pewds:PICKACHU?
P-P-PPICKACHU?
FUCKING PICKACHU
Did that guy just called me a FUCKING POKEMON???
Absolutely Correct. I am Pickachoo GUYS * I knew it*
I have an announcoment
I didn't think it will come out this way
But i do ... am in fact PICKACHU *good grammars*
thank you for supporting me
in my youtube channel
i will now proceed to pika-peak over here
ash....ash you bitch are you here ?
puudeeeche
puudeeche
The Guy: Ohh not breaking the... they are breaking pewdiepie look at this shit
Poods: Why would you break pewdiepie thats so mean *Poor pewdiepie but still a jerk*
The Guy : He took me 17 hours to build, alright? I even got his tickler. His tickler.
*ok he's gay* jesus christ
Felix: That guy is not impress by my tickler
I even got his tickler his tickler
YEAH (6 TIMES)
Same reaction ladies give as well
its... its fine am used to it
*NOW LETS HEAR MUSIC (Do You Really Want to Hurt Me - Culture Club) WHILE PUNCHING PEWDIEPIE SHALL WE??*
*MUSIC LAGS ON THE NEW VIRAL DANCE
The Guy: Just wonderin' if you'd like to collaborate sometime...
ON MY BED ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ;)
Pewds: Too far, man.
Too far.
*end video*